[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 78 lactu tout
de suite les titres de ce mercredi 18
juin le 11 juin 44 un bombardier de la
Royal Air Force s'écrasé à a encour 70
ans plus tard une plaque commémorative a
été dévoilée à l'occasion du 18 juin
jour de l'appel du Général de Gaulle à
en cours les propositions de la
municipalité en vue de l'application des
rythmes scolaires à la rentrée de
septembre ne séduisent pas une partie
des enseignants et des parents d'élèves
certains manifesteront ce jeudi devant
la mairie en plateau Débora sec
professeur des écoles Laeticia Gendron
parents d'élèves viendront dans quelques
instants nous exposer leur point de vue
il n'y a pas encore de déserts médicaux
dans les ivelines mais la situation est
critique notamment dans certaines zones
géographiques quel bilan tirit quelle
solution apporter le le point de vue de
professionnel de la santé c'est le
dossier du jour mais nous démarrons tout
de suite cette édition avec un hommage
pour le 70e anniversaire du débarquement
de Normandie la ville d'élencour rendait
hommage ce 18 juin aux aviateurs
britanniques morts pour la liberté le 11
juin 44 et commémorait l'appel du
général de Gaulle Anthony reche Patrick
JAC
dismud nous sommes le 10 juin 1944 peu
après 23h un avre Lancaster s'envole de
binbrook en Angleterre pour une mission
de bombardement sur la gare de triage
d'Acher les SEP membres d'équipage deux
Australiens trois britanniques et deux
Canadiens ont entre 21 et 28 ans après
avoir atteint leur objectif vers 1h du
matin ces soldats du 460e escadron se
font intercepté par la chasse de nuit
allemande et sont abatttu au-dessus du
lieudi le boulot Pelé aujourd'hui
localisé au parc des Coudrais 70 ans
après cet acte de bravoure leur mémoire
est honorée sous le regard ému de leur
famille toute ma vie j'ai vu des photos
de John donc très tôt j'ai toujours su
qui il était c'était un si joli garçones
défenseurs de la liberté reposent tous
au cimetière de viroflet sils ont péri
dans la nuit l' courtoise ils sont
devenus des frères d'armes exemplaires
pour les pilotes
britanniques c'est un tel sacrifice ils
se sont sacrifiés à cet endroit et c'est
trop souvent décrit de façon légère pour
prendre conscience de l'ampleur de leur
geste nous leur sommes tellement
redevables en cette journée du 18 juin
la commune a également rendu hommage au
général de Gaulle il y a 70 ans il
appelait à la poursuite des combats au
côté des alliés à la résistance et
Redonnet espoir à cette France battue
par l'Allemagne
Nazi les communes avaient jusqu 6 juin
pour représenter leur projet de réforme
scolaire faute de quoi c'est la
direction académique qui repren prit le
dossier en main à en cour le maire UMP
Jean-Michel Fourgous a été à
l'initiative d'une pétition pour
demander le report de cette réforme des
rythmes scolaire argumentant notamment
qu'elle coûtait trop cher à mettre en
place et je rappelle que dans cette
commune il y a 3100 écoliers et en
novembre 2013 il y a d'ailleurs eu une
motion qui a été votée en conseil
municipal pour demander l'abrogation de
la réforme et l'ouverture de
concertation alors justement est-ce
qu'il y a une concertation dans cette
commune visiblement pas et pour en
parler ce soir avec nous une enseignante
Débora sec bonsoir vous êtes enseignante
à l'école Alain Cavalier et puis une
parent d'élèves ou parente d'élèves je
ne sais pas comment on ditèv voilà
Létitia Gendron de également de l'école
Alain Cavalier alors sur cette réforme
des rythmes scolaires est-ce qu'il y a
d'abord eu une concertation à en cours
alors oui et non il y a 2 ans lorsqu'on
nous a annoncé la réforme c'est vrai que
Monsieur Fourgous avait décidé de faire
des groupes de travail on s'était
concerté parents enseignant et on était
arrivé à à une formule qui faisait à peu
près consensus c'est-à-dire 8h30 midi
13h45 15h45 avec ensuite la mise en
place de Tap temps d'activité
pércolaire à partir de 15h45 ensuite il
y a eu on avait plus de nouvelles de la
mairie on relançait on relançait c'était
à AB parce que entreemps il était du
chef de fil du boycotte effectivement
chef de fil d'une opposition qui ne
voulait plus mettre en place la la
réforme et finalement cette réforme elle
va devoir s'appliquer à la rentrée de
septembre et le choix qui a fait la
ville en tout cas ne semble pas vraiment
vous convenir hein c'est 8h45 le le
matin fin la classe à 16h30 avec une
pause méridienne très élargie entre
11h30 et 14h d'abord qu'est-ce que vous
reprochez à ces horaires alors ben déjà
on dit que le pic d'attention c'est le
matin d'où le mercredi matin rajouté et
on nous enlève 15 minutes par jour
d'enseignement alors 15 minutes ça
paraît rien du tout mais sur une année
scolaire ça fait 6 jours donc c'est un
peu dommage de de raccourcir le moment
où les enfants ont le plus d'attention
ensuite 2h 2h30 de pause méridienne
c'est énorme déjà 2h dans dans notre
école où il y a pas de préo les enfants
sont dans le froid donc c'est
problématique et puis finalement finir à
16h30 ça ça ça n' ça n'a pas du tout
raccourci la journée de nos élèves il y
a d'autres communes qui ont choisi de
faire des pauses méridiennes élargies je
pense notamment à la commune de de Guill
encou en estimant que finalement le midi
les enfants avaient quand même besoin de
de repos et du coup de pouvoir faire des
activités pour s'aérer d'esprit si je
peux résumer ou enfin 2 heur d'activité
c'est déjà pas mal hein les 10 alors
vous en tant que maman alors en tant que
maman il y a il y a un autre problème
qui se pose c'est bah l'aspect financier
mine de rien puisque ce quart d'heure a
été appelé par Monsieur Fourgous un
temps d'accueil périscolaire et non un
temps d'activité périscolaire ce qui ça
enfin voilà ça va être de la simple
garderie et du coup qui va être à la
charge des famille donc la plupart des
familles ne travaillont pas juste à un
quart d'heure de leur travail 90 % des
familles vont devoir déposer leurs
enfants avant 8h45 et donc ils vont
avoir une facture pour c'est un un non
sens quoi c'est un non sens et puis
effectivement le midi qu'on parle de
l'attention des enfants en maternelle ou
en élémentaire on voit bien que 2h de
pause pour faire déjeuner tous les
enfants c'est nécessaire mais c'est déjà
très long en maternelle ils ont des
temps d'attente qui sont très très longs
donc la reconcentration à 14h paraît
très difficile que ce soit en maternel
en élémentaire alors vous vous voudriez
quoi
idéalement vous êtes enseignant voudriez
quoi comme idéalement on voudrait
commencer à 8h30 euh continuer jusqu'à
midi parce qu'on se rend compte que à
11h30 les enfants sont encore tout à
fait disponibles dans les apprentissages
euh donc finir à midi reprendre à 13h45
ça fait à peu près 1h45 de pause
méridienne donc on peut même les grosses
écoles comme la nôtre peuvent manger en
deux trois services sans aucun souci
faire classe jusqu'à 15h45 et ensuite
faire l'étape 45 minutes pour faire des
activités construites que ça soit avec
les animateurs ou avec les enseignants
ça paraît plus raisonnable et plus
envisageable que faire 30 minutes comme
ça dans la précipitation où on sait que
les enfants en réalité vont avoir quoi
15 20 minutes dans
d'activités on parlera dans quelques
instants justement de l'aménagement des
temps périscolaires puisque le maire
d'lancour Jean-Michel Fourgous a évoqué
une possibilité lundi et visiblement
c'était une découverte pour beaucoup
d'enseignants de de la commune et je
reviens mais je vais reviens pardon sur
les sur les horaires je vous propose
justement d'écouter le maire le maire
UMP d'élancour sur cette question des
horaires mais c'est un grand débat parce
que arrêter l'école plutôt genre
15h30 ou 15h45 vous êtes en plein pic de
vigilance puisque vous avez deux pics de
vigilance 10 10 11h le matin et 15h
15h30 l'après-midi donc si vous arrêtez
les cours en plein milieu des du pic de
vigilance non c'est pas conforme au
rythme scolaire donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut au moins aller à 16h ou à 16h30
donc c'est pour ça que nous on disait on
met euh les tap dans la pause du
déjeuner pause méridienne voilà on prend
un quart d'heure le matin et on règlait
le problème donc ça changera rien pour
les parents c'était 8h30 16h30 donc les
les les les enseignants disent bon
est-ce que on pourrait peut-être euh que
ça se termine plusutôt bon on on va
discuter on va regarder on a discuté
avec eux mais mais on serait peut-être
plus d'accord de peut-être de remonter
un peu vers vers 16h au lieu de 16h30
mais à condition qu'il a des profs qui
s'impliquent pour la demi-heure par
exemple continuer ou à faire cours ou
avoir des ateliers avec nous voilà alors
les enseignants qui s'impliquent ça veut
dire qu'effectivement une partie des
temps péis scolaires des activités les
fameux tap qu on entend parler partout
pourra être pris en charge par les
enseignants est-ce que c'est une
solution que vous trouvez intéressante
alors d'abord je voudrais dire répondre
à Monsieur fourgou sur les
chronobiologistes le problème c'est que
c'est pas une science exact vous
pourriez avoir 10 personnes sur votre
plateau cinq qui vous diraient qu'ils
sont d'accord avec lui sur les pics de
vigilance à 15h45 deux qui vous diraient
peut-être c'est peut-être voilà donc
dire ça maintenant vous qui vous êtes
enseign je constate que les enfants ils
sont plus disponible le matin que à
15h30 à partir de 15h30 on sent bien que
il y a quand même une excitation une
fatigue après quand on veut impliquer
les les enseignants peut-être faut les
prévenir à l'avance parce que que les
avertir lundi soir lors de la réunion
qui était sollicité par les directeurs
et pas par Monsieur fourgouss et les
mettre un peu sur le fait accompli on
compte sur vous pour l'organisation
c'est un petit peu embêtant est-ce que
on
s'impliquerait oui pour certains
collègues non pour d'autres je peux pas
répondre pour tout le monde sur une
demi-heure ça me paraît complètement
déraisonnable parce qu'on ferait pas
quelque chose de qualité sur 45 minutes
je pense qu'il y aurait peut-être plus
de collègues qui seraient d'accord et
malgré tout il y a quand même une petite
polémique qui est en train de naître sur
la formation des animateurs don on on
sent que c'est un peu compliqué pour les
villes de recruter ces fameux animateurs
qui soit correctement formés donc on
peut dire je sais pas quand on est
parent d'élèves on peut dire que c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle si les
enseignants prennent en charge ces
fameux tap ben je suis pas sûr parce que
on connaît enfin l'importance du travail
des enseignants et rajouter une
demi-heure on sait qu'ils ont des
préparations à faire une demi journée
qui va être ajoutée sur le midi on sait
très bien enfin qu'il y a des réunions
qui s'organisent pour des activités qui
font dans les classes et euh enfin moi
je vais parler pour Alain Cavalier on a
des animateurs qui sont enfin qui ont
l'air assez compétents pour encadrer les
enfants je suis sûr qu'il y en a plein
qui ont des compétences peut-être
spécifiqu peut-être du théâtre peut-être
de l'art plastique pour certains le
problème c'est que je pense que Monsieur
Fourgous n'est pas allé leur demander
quand on leur demande donc c'est bien
qu'fin voilà ils sont au courant
d'absolument rien on leur a même pas
demandé leur avis donc alors je pense
qu'il y a certainement un vivier de
connaissance et en tout cas de
compétences à exploiter chez les
animateurs même des lancours quelle que
soit leur formation on va réécouter le
maire des lancour parce qu'on on comme
ça vous pourrez réagir on lui a posé la
question pour pour qu'il explique
pourquoi il souhaite que les enseignants
fasse des TAP s'implique dans les tap on
écoute on pense nous que de démultiplier
les animateurs pour quelques heure de
toute façon c'est un personnel que vous
avez du mal à fidéliser donc en fait il
est il y a beaucoup de turn over d'après
les communes qui ont déjàessé la
première année c'est un circle pas
possible bon donc c'est vrai qu'on
préférait avoir des références stables
et et donc des profs donc si les profs
peuvent bien entendu un certain nombre
peuvent s'impliquer dans dans ces
fameuses tap enfin ce fameux
périscolaire en dehors de l'école ça
nous coûte plus cher bien sûr parce que
les profs coûtent deux fois plus cher
que l'animateur mais c'est dit il nous
semble que on maîtriserait ce facteur de
risque d'avoir autant d'animateurs qui
encadrent des enfants al une réaction
quand même c'est intéressant ce que dit
Jean-Michel fous il parle de référents
stable c'est important d'avoir des
références stables et aussi il parle de
ce phénomène de risque d'avoir une
multiplication des animateurs dans dans
les oui alors c'est vrai que s'il a
décidé ça à la dernière minute c'est sûr
qu'il va avoir plus de mal à recruter
des animateurs compétents que si s était
prêt 6 mois 1 an à l'avance euh après il
va falloir gérer auprès des enseignants
euh parce qu'on va avoir la double
casquette l'enseignant qui enseigne en
classe et l'étape c'est du périscolaire
alors euh il va falloir voir comment ça
peut se gérer euh pour les collègues
euh àoir puisque comme c'est tout
nouveau on n pas le recul pour c'est pas
vous êtes pas contre tout à fait vous
attendez de voir peut-être un peu plus
alors vous enz peut-être un peu plus
demain parce que au moment même où vous
êtes en plateau en direct à 18h10 le
maire d'lancour fait une conférence de
presse et si vous aviez quel chose à lui
dire demandez allez-y il vous écoute
pas je lui demanderai de de tenir compte
du consensus qui s'était fixé toutes les
écoles et les parents d'élèves qui
avaient répondu au sondage étaient
d'accord sur 8h30
midi 13h45 15h45 donc je lui demanderai
de respecter la vie de la plus grande
majorité et puis de de communiquer
davantage avec enseignants et et parents
d'élèves parce que les parents d'élèves
à ce jour n'ont pas reçu de courrier ne
sont pas au courant de ce qui va se
passer l'année prochaine on n pas eu de
courrier officiel de la de la mairie et
moi je lui dirais aussi de d'utiliser
toutes les associations qui sont sur H
encs et qui sont prêtes on sait que
certaines sont prêtes à aider pour ces
famill activités périscolair tap
manifestation est prévue jeudi soir n un
rassemblement ah alors un rassemblement
est prévu jeudi soir devant l'hôtel de
ville des lancour c'est pas l'hôtel de
ville c'est au rond-point des Lyons
rondoint des
lon est-ce que ce rassemblement est
toujours prévuité oui oui oui tout à
fait on a affiché donc on espère être
nombreux ce combat est est politique non
du tout d'accord parce que vous nêtes
pas syndiqué voilà c'est important
d'cune fédération de parentsélèv
éctronbre électron libre ben merci en
tout cas à vous deux d'être venu sur PL
téléfil 78 et je rappelle qu'un
rassemblement se tiendra donc je dis
soir de devant sur le rond-point des lon
à aoncour pas très loin de la mairie
merci beaucoup allez on chance de sujet
on va parler santé les déserts médicaux
ce n'est pas seulement réservé aux zones
rurales ou à la province le département
des Yvelines est également concerné
alors pour inciter les professionnels de
santé à rester dans le département un
cololloc séduction était organisé ce
mardi à l'initiative de
l'URPS ce jour-là Catherine Dorkel
chargée de mission à Manille et à mot
joue la VRP elle est venue à ce colloque
à la Faculté de médecine de 50 ans en
Yveline en quête d'un médecin
généraliste cela fait un an qu'elle
cherche la perle rare à manilé Amou on a
seulement quatre médecins généralistes
dont deux à mi-temps donc effectivement
il y a une forte demande on a un médecin
généraliste qui qui quitte la commune
pour des raisons personnelles et on a un
local en construction qui sera bientôt
terminé d'ici
fin décembre où il y a la possibilité
d'installer dans 70 m² un médecin
généraliste voire deux si mutualise il y
a 70 m² avec un loyer plus que abordable
un cons ça adressé également par cette
kinésithérapeute installer en zone
rurale on a passé des annonces et on on
trouve personne pour l'instant et ça
c'est la plus grosse difficulté je pense
c'est recruter des personnes pour Ben
pour répondre à la demande de soins quoi
beaucoup de jeunes veulent travailler
sur Paris même ou dans la proche
couronne mais dès qu'on s'éloigne un
tout petit peu de de de Paris en fait
bah il faut un véhicule il y a moins de
moyens de transport et donc ça attire
moins les les jeunes je pense on essaie
de ou d'être le plus attractif possible
c'est vrai que nous on va changer de
cabinet pour avoir un cabinet auorm
handicapé trouver un médecin même dans
les Ines cela peut sembler compliqué
mais comment l'expliquer dans les 4 5
ans qui vont venir on sait qu'il y a 20
% des médecins notamment médecins
généralistes qui vont partir à la
retraite et les jeunes sont pas encore
formés pour les remplacer donc on va
avoir 4 5 ans difficiles le problème est
que le monde libéral n'attire plus les
jeunes médecins ils savent faire très
bien la comparaison
entre la sécurité du système public et
puis les difficultés actuelles du monde
libéral et leur choix est étouffit il
faut leur faciliter leur exercice au
quotidien et
aussi regarder les rémunérations les
jeunes générations on envie d'avoir un
certain confort de vie quand vous êtes
généraliste vous êtes app cl à toute
heure et cetera donc c'est compliqué de
concilier vie privée vie professionnelle
et donc les gens se dirigent plus vers
des structures de salariat le
département compte 1700 médecins
généralistes cela peut sembler
satisfaisant mais les disparités
géographiques sont importantes et
d'autres secteurs sont en sous-effectif
comme la psychiatrie et la gynécologie
même constat pour la filière
paramédicale Nathalie Kiss est
orthophoniste pour elle le frein
principal c'est le manque de locaux le
premier frein et bien c'est les locaux
et que à partir du moment où on mettra
davantage de locaux ça se à disposition
des des médicaux et paramédicaux ça
deviendra un facteur facilitant on gagne
pas autant qu'un médecin généraliste
donc on est très regardant sur le
montant du loyer et on peut louer que
des petites surfaces voilà donc pour moi
c'était un gros problème le prix des
loyers cela impacte aussi les cabinets
de groupe qui deviennent de plus en plus
fragiles économiquement l'Union
régionale des professionnels de a lancé
de son côté une pétition pour les
soutenir une pétition à retrouver en
ligne allez toujours dans le domaine de
la santé l'association externa
médicoéducative d'lancour vient de fêter
ses 30 ans c'était aujourd'hui même à
cette occasion enfants parents et
employés ont été invités à une journée
festive au programme clown jeu apéritif
et buffet le me donc l'externa est un
centre d'accueil pour jeunes polis
handicapés la structure fait partie du
pôle enfance de l'association apage 78
et à la manière d'une école elle propose
un accompagnement éducatif mais on y
trouve aussi de l'aide médicale et
psychologique en lien avec toute la
famille beaucoup de sollicitations mais
peu de place l'me souhaite donc
s'agrandir c'est l'un des projets à
venir on écoute d'ailleurs à ce sujet
Birgitte Villain c'est la directrice du
pôle enfant de la page 78 on
a comme projet éventuellement de
proposer une halte garderie pour les
plus jeunes ça veut dire accueillir des
plus jeunes pendant une ou deux
demi-journée par semaine pour soulager
les familles on a aussi le projet bien
sûr pour tout cela il faudra le
financement après bien sûr hein de que
des jeunes puissent éventuellement
passer une nuit ici parce que pour
certaines familles c'est très lourd he
le jeune qui rentre tous les soirs à la
maison ou d'ouvrir aussi au plus petit
amnestie internationale les reçoit en
France le temps d'une dizaine de jours
de Palestiniens sont venus parler de
leurs conditions de vie chez eux dans un
village de 6 Jordanie nous les avvez
rencontrés à Versailles à l'occasion
d'une conférence débat un sujet signé
yolen
Torz ils ont été invités par la section
française d'amnestie internationale de
Palestiniens se sont arrêtés à
Versailles pour parler de leur
conditions de vie chez eux dans le
village de nabisalé un village situé en
six Jordanie et dont une partie des
terres est occupée par des colons
israéliens àlass Tamimi et la mère de
Mustapha tué en décembre 2011 lors d'une
manifestation pacifique un soldat de
l'État israélien lu aurait jeté une
grenade lamogène dans le
visage je suis venu pour porter un
message en France mais aussi dans les
pays
arabes pour que ce soldat soit
jugé et que tous les enfants
palestiniens soi
protégés nos conditions de vie peuvent
s'améliorer si la colonisation cesse et
si les Palestiniens peuvent bénéficier
de leurs propres droits et parmi ces
droits le droit à l'autodétermination et
la mise en place d'un État démocratique
les deux Palestiniens prennent ensuite
la direction de Bruxelles ils vont
peut-être y rencontrer des
parlementaires européens afin d'obtenir
des soutiens
politiques et un sujet culture pour
terminer la Corée invité d'honneur du
château de Versailles l'artiste coréen
l'ufan expose ses œuvres contemporaines
inédites jusqu'au 2 novembre des œuvres
en extérieur qui s'inspirent des jardins
de Le Nôtre une rencontre entre l'art et
la nature Aurelia debissi etodi
moine monumental l'arche métallique du
scul liuan tel un arc-en-ciel surplombe
la grande perspective du château de
Versailles après les arbres en bronze de
l'artiste italien penoné pour sa
traditionnelle exposition d'art
contemporain le domaine de Versailles
accueille cette année les œuvres du
coréen liufan 10 installations
méditatives et minimalistes fait de
Pierre naturell et d'acier jalonne les
jardins conçu par André Le nôre la
pierre représentant la nature et l'acier
comme symbole de la société
industrialisée un parcours qui offre off
une autre vision des jardins une autre
manière de regarder l'espace qui nous
[Musique]
entoure sans parler de son histoire le
jardin est si parfait un peu trop
parfait et je me suis dit qu'est-ce que
je peux faire à ce moment-là j'avais
l'impression que André Le Nôtre était en
train de me parler et me disait voilà je
t'offre cet espace si parfait fais-moi
quelque chose de différent et je te
regarderai c'est pour ça que je me suis
dit que c'était un lieu idéal pour
montrer ce que je pense ce n'est pas une
idée une image ni non plus un objet
exposé en fait je dialogue avec l'espace
donné puis j'essaie de trouver une idée
qui laisse justement la place à l'espace
qui invite les gens à regarder le ciel à
regarder la nature finalement je vous
montre comme l'univers l'infini dépasse
ce
perfectionnement outre large de versaill
les œuvres de Luan sont disposé de façon
à faire revivre les recoins des jardins
peu fréquentés à l'instar du Bosquet du
dauphin ou encore du Bosquet des
étoiles
[Musique]
le sculpteur rend également hommage à
André Le Nôtre avec une tombe installée
dans le bosquet des bains d'Apollon
habituellement fermé au public les
œuvres de l'ufan rythmeront le parcours
de visite jusqu'au 2
novembre voilà j'espère que les l'œuvre
de l'île Ufan vous aura inspiré cette
édition est maintenant terminée merci de
votre attention rendez-vous demain à 18h
pour le journal en direct dans quelques
instants vous avez rendez-vous avec
kiosque l'émission culturelle présentée
par Aurelia de Biss bonne
[Musique]
soirée